Thank you sir.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Picking up where we left off yesterday
morning in the narration of
in
narration number 41 the chapter of
patience.
says,
he said, "We came complaining to the
messenger of Allah sau
one day while he was sitting on a
cloak that he had spread spread out for
himself in the shade of the Caba.
[Silence]
They came to complain to the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam about their
tormentors from amongst Quraysh and we
had a little insight yesterday morning
into some of the difficulties that they
were going through especially
we said
will you not
then seek seek victory for us from
Allah.
Will you not
pray for us? Make dua that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala end this torment,
this hardship.
And we remember that
when it comes to difficulty
and hardship,
if every time a person is faced with an
adversity
and they pray it away
and as soon as they raise their hands in
dua, it is gone.
Who suffers from such a thing? We do. We
suffer. Why? Because
our nu
our nefs can only be made better
by way of knowledge and difficulty.
Knowledge and difficulty. Knowledge and
difficulty. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions these two together throughout
the Quran.
When Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
water and fire, look at the parables he
mentions. He'll always mention or often
throughout the Quran, he will give an
analogy of water. He will give then an
analogy of fire. He'll give an analogy
of water, an analogy of fire. Even the
first analogy he gave in all of the
Quran
he mentions subhanahua
he gave an example of the hypocrites
and the first analogy he gave was an
analogy
connected to fire and then the second
analogy he gave
And the second analogy he gave was a
hard rain. So we have fire and water.
These two are hand in hand throughout
the Quran. Fire and water. And Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions these two
in a very critical verse in the Quran
which speaks about
how Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala purifies
the hearts of men. How does he purify
the hearts of men? How does he mold and
shape men into
people that are
eligible for paradise that are not only
eligible for paradise but are of the
highest order of the people of paradise.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions that
he sends down rain from the heavens.
This is an example, an analogy of the
Quran,
an analogy of revelation. He sends down
rain from above.
And each
valley then takes in this rain
as much as the valley is wide. Each
valley when the water comes down, it
fills up the earth.
And each valley between two mountains,
each stream will take in how much of
this water? It will take in as much as
it can hold of this water. Each valley
will take in as much of it as it can
bear based on its size.
the valleys here in this verse.
This is an analogy for the hearts of
men.
So we have Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us in this verse this is in surah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says that he
sent down rain from the heavens
and when the rain reaches the earth
each valley carries of this rain to its
capacity
based on the valley's size. Some valleys
are bigger, some valleys are more
narrow, some valleys are more deep, some
valleys are more shallow the hearts
of men. Some hearts are more wide, can
take in more of this revelation, and
some are more narrow and can only focus
on some of this on some of this
revelation.
And so the rain is the Quran and the
Sunnah and revelation and wisdom.
And the valleys in this parable
are the hearts of men.
And so when the rain accumulates,
it turns into a stream in these valleys.
And this stream starts to take up the
trash that is in this valley and push it
to the surface.
When this rain continues
hard,
it starts to form a stream. This stream
starts to pick up all of the impurities,
all of the trash from
the
floor or the bed of of the valley and
push it to the top and wash it out. That
is the garbage. That is the trash. That
is the disease that is found in the
hearts of men.
Allah subhanahu waala will send down
this rain.
Each valley will take up as much of the
rain as it can. And if this process
continues, it will form a stream that
will start to purify
the
floor and purify the valleys.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says that the
stream will become strong enough that it
now pushes the trash and the impurities
to the top and it forms a foam on top of
this stream that it flushes out at the
end.
Then he moves over in the same analogy
he says
He transitions. He pivots from the
analogy of water and the valley and the
stream and the impurities and the
effects that the Quran has on the heart.
He pivots to the
goldsmith
and the
kiln of the goldsmith which is the
oven that the goldsmith uses to bring
the gold to boiling point in order to
purify it.
this gold. When you see the raw gold or
the raw silver, the raw material,
when you see that the goldsmith or the
jeweler puts it into the oven, it starts
to melt and then it starts to push the
impurities to the top.
Just the impurities being pushed to
the top
in the
rivers and in the valleys that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala sent down the rain
upon
that foam and those impurities coming to
the top in that heat is reminiscent of
the
foam and the impurities being pushed to
the top in that raging in that raging
stream. Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala then
says
this is the parable of truth and
falsehood that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
gives the analogy that he strikes. He
says,
he said, "Ask for that foam,
right? All that busy work on top of the
stream, on top of the gold or silver,
all that that's carrying all that
impurity,
all of that goes by the wayside and is
discarded.
And as for what is of benefit to human
beings, then it remains in the earth.
The pure water remains in those valleys.
The pure gold remains
around the necks of
remains as a beautifification
for mankind.
So what does this verse have to do with
this narration?
We mentioned that
came asking for dua that Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
alleviates
the hardship that they are encountering
from their enemies.
However, that hardship is not just
is not just something that we should
focus on avoiding and getting past. Why?
Because that hardship is necessary
just that heat and that oven is
necessary to purify that gold. This
hardship that is taking place that is
the heat Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is
subjecting
truth and falsehood to simultaneously
the believers
are becoming more pure
and the disbelievers
are becoming more and more separated
from the gold and silver and precious
metals. And so simultaneously the good
are becoming better, the bad are
becoming worse and they are making their
way to being discarded.
And so what are these two parables? Why
are they mentioned together?
Revelation
and hardship.
and tribulation.
Revelation
and fitna. hardship.
These two things when a person has
revelation,
they receive revelation from Allah and
then they go through difficulties that
they have to reshape themselves to not
at a superficial level but at a deep
deep level
when they are faced with adversity.
That is the water and the fire they go
hand in hand.
And as the person receives more water,
receives more fire, receives more water,
receives more fire, at the end of that
process, a person becomes
of the people who are worthy of being
close to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. And
that's why we were created. That's the
whole reason we were created.
We will tie this in inshallah
Saturday with the narration.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.